>>> THERE'S A NEW BIPARTISAN
BI BEING PUT FORT  TRAIN
UKRAINIAN PILOTS ON U.S. MADE
FIGHTEJETS AND OTHER MILITARY
HARDWARE THAT COULD GIVE IT AN
EDGE IN DEFENDING ITSELF AGAINST
DEVASTATING RUSSIAN ATTACKS.
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER SAYS
THE TRAINING COULD HAPPEN AS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WEIGHS
SENDING THOSE JETS TO UKRAINE.
THIS WEEK I SAT DOWN WITH SEAN
PENN IN WASHINGTON URGING
LAWMAKERS TO MEET WITH TWO OF
UKRAINE'S TOP AIR FORCE PILOTS
WHO HAVE BEEN PUSHING TO GET
MORE MILITARY AIRCRAFT FOR
UKRAINE.
HERE'S WHY SEAN PENN SAID THAT
AID IS SO CRITICAL.
>> THAT THE ASK IS NOT A BIG
GRAND ASK.
IT'S A VERY PRACTICAL ASK TO BE
ABLE TO MATCH THE AIR TECHNOLOGY
OF THE RUSSIAN FIGHTERS.
AT THIS POINT THEY'RE NYING THE
EQUIVALENT OF SUICIDE MISSIONS
AND ALL THEY NEED IS THE MOST
BASIC SUPPORT FROM THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> YOU HEAR ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT TAKE PLACE
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
PEOPLE HERE IN WASHINGTON ARE
WORRIED ABOUT ESCALATING THINGS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
IF WE GIVE THEM THIS ASSISTANCE,
IT WILL ESCALATE THE WAR, MAYBE
DRAG THE UNITED STATES IN.
>> YEAH, I'M NOT A BELIEVER IN
THAT PHILOSOPHY OF THOUGHT.
I THINK THAT VERY CLEARLY IF WE
HAD ANNOUNCED WHAT WE WERE GOING
TO DO, THAT WE HAVE DONE IN
SUPPORT OF UKRAINE TO THIS DATE,
THAT WOULD ALSO HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED A WILD ESCALATION.
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE ITS
NATURAL COURSE.
THE UNNATURAL COURSE ARE THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WE'RE LETTING
DIE EVERY DAY AND THE AMOUNT OF
DESTRUCTION WE'RE LETTING HAPPEN
IN UKRAINE EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT
WE PUT OFF THE INEVITABLE.
THE INEVITABLE IS NOT NUCLEAR
WAR.
THE INEVITABLE IS THAT THE
UKRAINIANS WILL WIN THIS WAR AND
IF THEY ARE GIVEN THE EQUIPMENT
TODAY, YOU HAD ASKED THE
QUESTION HAVING TO DO WITH HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE, HOW LONG IT
TAKES IS THAT FROM THE DAY THAT
THESE AIRCRAFT ARE DELIVERED TO
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE FOUR MONTHS FROM
THAT DATE THEY'LL BE IN THE AIR
FIGHTING THIS WAR.
>> AND JOINING ME NOW ARE THE
TWO UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE PILOTS
WHO GO BY THE CALL EVENS
MOONFISH AND JUICE WHICH WE ARE
USING TODAY TO PROTECT THEIR
IDENTITIES.
YOU CAN SEE THEY'RE ALL WEARING
THEIR MASKS AND WE ALL MET
EARLIER ALONGSIDE SEAN PENN.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOONFISH AND JUICE FOR BEING
WITH ME.
YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE UKRAINE'S
TOP GUN PILOT, RIGHT, BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE THE BEST TECHNOLOGY.
>> YEAH, IT IS CORRECT.
>> AND WHAT WOULD THAT DO IN
TERMS OF MAKING A DIFFERENCE FOR
YOU IN DEFENDING UKRAINE AND
DEFENDING YOUR PEOPLE?
>> WELL, IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AIR TO AIR SUPERIORITY SO
BASICALLY THE RUSSIANS HAVE
OBVIOUS TECHNICAL ADVANTAGES
OVER OUR FIGHTER JETS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT -- THE NUMBERS SAY
THAT PROVIDING US WITH U.S. MADE
FIGHTER JETS WOULD MAKE US AT
LEAST MATCHING THEM OR I BELIEVE
EVEN MORE ADVANCED.
ON THE OTHER HAND, PROVIDING
THOSE JETS IS ALSO WE SEE IT AS
A VERY IMPORTANT THING TO
PROTECT UKRAINE